like i said this is from the 2011 paper
so we're going back 10 years unlike some
of the other topics like say vectors and
proof which are newer to the extension 2
course
mechanics and particularly this kind of
mechanics question has been in the
course for a very long time so fun fact
if you went and downloaded the hsc paper
for this you might have noticed that
it's from a time
before nessa was called nessa we used to
call it the board of studies or the
board for uh for short
and there were some great there was some
great puns on that because people were
like uh i'm so bored of studies anyway
that's um that's by the by what do i
like about this question and what do i
think is worth having a look at okay
well
fact one which you don't need me to tell
you because uh it's a common
characteristic of pretty much all the
hse questions we have go out this
question was not done very well across
the state
particularly in this last part uh about
15 of the state got part 3 there which i
think you'll find surprising when we get
to the solution and you have a look at
it you're like yeah it's not that bad
really three hallmarks worth of um
effort for this uh
i think a lot of people as you've seen
frequently get intimidated by this
question and see like whoa there's so
much here it's one of those whole pages
um as i often call them
but if you can see through um this sort
of abundance of details some of which
are less relevant than others i think
you'll find the actual working and the
thinking and the concept behind this
really quite manageable okay so that's
the first thing that it's it was
something that wasn't done well even
though there's no reason for that i
don't think by the way if you're
wondering
2011 question 6a you're like question 6
isn't that multiple choice uh i said
this was going a while back this is
before there was multiple choice in the
extension two paper so um back in these
days yeah it was this is actually fairly
middling of the road um there were you
know eight questions as a whole and so
this was like this was this was less of
a oh no i've run out of time uh question
um
students were really quite troubled by
it and didn't know what to do so that's
the first major thing the second thing
to notice is that um
this is a question that i think does a
really great good job of using terminal
velocity which you can see part one is
to work out terminal velocity and that's
quite a straightforward result that's
why there's only one mark on it there's
only a handful of very very brief lines
of working which i will show you shortly
terminal velocity part of the pun is
usually where the question ends you're
like okay do all of this stuff and then
tell me terminal velocity and it doesn't
usually go anywhere because like what do
you use that for but if you have even
just a cursory look at parts two and
three show you that part one working out
terminal velocity is not a coincidence
they want you to use look at how many
times
v t which is their their
designation for terminal velocity look
how many times it appears in parts two
and three i count one two three four
five uh six seven eight times throughout
those those two parts there at the end
of the question so you're clearly going
to need to use that result in part one
quite substantially in parts two and
three so i really like that
so let me just give you um before i send
you off to work on this independently i
mean you're probably sort of already
doing that in the background let me give
you one more sort of overview and as
promised a nudge into the question
you've got two people who are jumping
out of an airplane with parachutes
thankfully you've got jack and jill see
what they did there
you only get introduced to jack in the
beginning jill comes in in part three
but the whole idea is you get given a
fairly classic
vertical resisted motion situation right
they're jumping out they pull their
parachute and so you've got gravity
pulling them downwards but then you've
got this parachute pushing up against
them and it's got this kv-squared
it's a quadratic drag situation so
that's going to be important for when we
put together our equations of motion one
of which they've given to us it says
jack's equation of motion with the
parachute open is here it is it says do
not prove this now i should point out
even though they've said don't prove it
it's not that big a deal can you see
where it's come from
force equals mass times acceleration and
you can see it right there in the left
hand side there's mass times
acceleration this is just one of the
classic forms for um you know
acceleration alongside x double dot d
half v squared on dx etc okay
so you've got force on the left hand
side and then here's the two forces like
i mentioned gravity and then um
drag due to air resistance okay we're
not going to prove that we're just going
to use that as a starting point
see daisy let's click off of that there
we go so
from that it says explain why jack's
terminal velocity vt is given by
that square root of mg on k so i think
you guys can get that and only take a
few lines my nudge into this question is
just for part two
when you have a look at part two it says
by integrating the equation of motion so
they give you a big fat like go in this
direction okay um they don't leave it up
to chance and they've even chosen
they've even designated the form for
acceleration which is often a classic
part of the question like tell me which
form is the most appropriate right
they've already done that out of the
gate by telling us jack's equation of
motion in this particular format you
don't have to do anything particularly
dramatic to it
but this equation here t equals etc etc
etc it just looks weird right you're
like what's going on here the appearance
of not only the terminal velocity but
the initial velocity
v zero um we're just this is a kind of
strange way to phrase the result okay so
my clue for you is to say knowing that
as in all proof questions you always
have one eye on where you're headed and
then another eye on your present working
you clearly need to bring terminal
velocity and
your initial velocity into this equation
relating t and v okay
so you can see them there and i also
want you to notice what's not there
there's a bunch of um pronumerals that
do not appear in this part to result
that we're required to prove so whatever
results and whatever pronumerals are not
there if they appear in your integration
you're going to need to do something to
eliminate them or substitute to get them
away okay
so that is enough clues hopefully
hopefully it's enough to um to get you
there it's 7 43
44 rather so i'm going to give you till
let's call it 752 but i would love you
to post in the chat as you make progress
uh maybe you might say mr wu i'm ready
to go let's or or you know i'm um i've
got a solution or i feel like i've i've
gone as far as i can and i'm just
hitting my head against the brick wall
i'm not making progress either way um
and i'll
get i'll sort of prompt you um when we
get close to that to give me a sense of
whether you need more time or not okay
so i'm gonna turn my mic off good luck
and uh we'll come back together in a few
minutes here's what i'm gonna do it
sounds like everyone's at a different
spot which is which is good um some of
you have noticed that part two
actually is harder than part three in a
variety of ways and i'm gonna i'm gonna
show you um why i think that is the case
um it made me a little perplexed like
when i looked at the um
the marking scheme for part three i i
said i registered surprise that there
were three marks assigned to this um but
i'll make an argument for that for that
in a second okay so let's have a go
through we'll begin with part one which
i think was fairly uncontroversial um
and then we'll get stuck into this this
troublesome part two that people are
experiencing
so just to review we've got this
equation of motion that's been handed to
us
force on the left hand side mass times
acceleration and then you've got your
two vertical components one going up one
going down noticing that they've defined
for us vt is positive in the downwards
direction and so that's why gravity is
positive and this resistive force is
negative which is which is going up okay
explain why jack's terminal velocity vt
is given by square root of mg on k now
um do be careful usually when you see an
explained question
it is almost a guarantee that you have
to use some kind of verbal argument
that's kind of what explanation often
entails i think this is one of the few
circumstances where you can pretty much
get away with some well set out clearly
communicated algebra so here's the way
i'm going to do it
we're trying to explain what terminal
velocity is right and use as little
effort as i can so the whole idea is
that your velocity approaches terminal
velocity so i would say that v
approaches v t
under what condition like what is the
most useful way to say it and i would
say based on the equation of motion
when your acceleration here dv on dt
when that's going towards zero like the
whole idea of terminal velocity is once
you get there i mean you can't
physically get there in a theoretical
situation because you're always
approaching but never quite getting
there
but the whole idea is that your
acceleration is getting closer and
closer to zero your your
velocity is no longer changing very much
that's a whole idea of terminal velocity
it's where you terminate so therefore
i'm going to say this
this limit happens as dv on dt
acceleration approaches zero and all i'm
going to do is take both of those ideas
and sort of substitute them into there's
no obstacle or division by zero or
anything like that
by for substituting them into that
equation of motion that's provided so
i've got m
times dv dt on the left-hand side which
in this case i'm regarding it as 0
and that's equal to
on the right-hand side i've got my
gravity force and then i would normally
say kv squared but here i'm now saying
well if i've gotten to this place this
mythical theoretical place where my
acceleration is zero then i won't have
kv squared i'll have k of vt
squared right does that make sense and
then there's really not much more to
getting i mean you can see the result
that's required to prove is vt as a
subject so i just need to do some very
basic rearrangement
um i will add
the
k
v t squared to both sides that left hand
side is 0 because m times 0 you just get
that mg on the right i'll divide through
by k
which gives me the mg on k which you can
see appearing in that result now i just
need to take the square root yes so i'll
say vt is equal to that square root
right there and
i mean i've gotten so far without using
any words except the word as um so here
it probably
does warrant saying that here velocity
i'm taking the positive for vt because
um i'm assuming
you know uh the resistance is never
going to be enough to push them like to
be flying like actually upwards they'll
slow down going downwards but they'll
never be going upwards so that's why my
v which downwinds is defined as positive
gives me that okay
so there's part one like i said probably
didn't need that much explanation but at
least we're all on the same page and i
hope if your notation was a little bit
different you can see how mine hopefully
makes it clear we will return to this
result we're going to need it to use it
a fair bit for parts 2 and 3.